[Musik]
direkt an der küste kaliforniens sandra
und rolli sind auf amerika reise doch es
sind keine normalen ferien vor einigen
jahren erfuhr sander dass sie das kind
eines samenspenders ist seit sie davon
weiß sucht sandra ihre wurzeln und kommt
nicht mehr zur ruhe
wie lässt sich der biologische vater
finden
woher stammt die andere hälfte ihre gene
solche fragen werden zum alles
beherrschenden thema für sandra eine
antwort hat sie endlich in kalifornien
gefunden
[Musik]
sander ist in der nähe von winterthur
aufgewachsen
ich bin eigentlich so früher als kind
kommt und der torte mitten in österreich
will es einfach immer kaiser hatte beim
richter familie zog so ganz anders stoss
wird auch in die verwandten und das
heißt sie zog sie aus und wolfgang das
ist ja ich schon gern manche verschönere
ich mache ihnen mit dem aber freut ich
finde das einfach sehr schön ja man
kunden glücklich sind
sandras eigenes leben zum glück bekam
mit anfang 30 je einen riss und sie das
familiengeheimnis von einer eingeweihten
unbedacht verraten würde ich dann
erfahren dass mein vater nicht mehr
biologische vater ist
und ja das hat dann ziemlich mal selber
keine familie mobile selber bin mir
selber ist denn eigentlich wirklich der
erste blick hinspiel wuchs sie im mini
augen und ich habe mich wirklich gefragt
wo ich die andere hälfte muss ich mich
unter 50 prozent
ich denke man kann ich wirklich dank
dich ich muss einfach zu finden
ich muss erfinder werden im biologischen
vater ist nicht nur auf das was ihn auch
in sondern auch nach mir selber als
eines der ersten kinder in der schweiz
wurde sandra anfangs der 70er jahre bei
einer medizinisch durchgeführten
samenspende gezeugt
für ihre mutter war das kein einfacher
schritt und der bin eben auf zürich zum
frauenarzt oder und der hat eine
bäckerei mit café und dann hat der
rebellen spanta kandidaten hans dass er
so gemacht
eigentlich war es anders vater wegen
einer erkrankung im teenager-alter
unfruchtbar
auch er stimmte dem geheim gehaltenen
eingriff zu das haben und das haben ihre
sorgen los ja ich habe das nicht von mir
gemacht wird das ist ja was ich
besprochen worden und will er gern reden
dort und hat gesagt ja so ist das für
ihn das thema der herz behindert wenn
sie in jagen wird zwei töchter wurden
mittels verschiedener samenspende
gezeugt die ärzte beschworen die eltern
dies den kindern niemals zu erzählen
nach rhodos kos ho chi minh triet an dem
auch sandra und dann hat sie ist unter
druck sein kann
harnik für mutter und schwester war das
ganze kein großes thema sandra hingegen
konnte keinen er mehr zu ihrem sozialen
vater empfinden
er starb kurze zeit später seitdem
verfolgt sondern eine andere spur
das ist aber jetzt die familie wunschbox
und dabei fehler ein wunsch oder wünsche
rufs weber und jetzt eine die blicke der
wichtigste wunsch ist dass ich meine
biologische vater winter wird ich habe
der wunsch sich kriegsgebiet und ich bin
jetzt schon seit 14 jahren so mache ich
an dem frauenarzt vom in ihrem alter
blüte
am morgen und haben im st wer ich bin
und wenig entstanden bin und ich kann
ihn sich schon bald über mich an halfen
und ja mir a half men seele frieden
finde er hat mir dann einfach die
anhaltspunkte zeit auf erden heißt das
eher amerikanisch und das was ein
medizinstudent vor ihm und mehr hat mir
dann immer verraten
und ich kann ihn wirklich wahnsinnig
darum patinierte vor die namen sagen
wenn du mit mir wurde nach und man nicht
wie im internet und damit recherchieren
da hat man keine chance verstanden und
ich kann wirklich glaube bei zweiten
heirat schwarz und in einfach so button
dass er mir das einfach sagen und das
für mich einfach wahnsinnig wichtig ist
dass ich das weiß
es geht ja wirklich nicht um
irgendwelche finanziell ist auch
belästigungen es geht einfach darum dass
man nicht wisse wohl dass nach unten
sind die wurzel kann tja aber er ist die
beliebtheit
auch sander bleibt stur jetzt nach
vielen jahren vergeblichen suchens
pflegt sie zusammen mit ihrem partner
roland nach amerika dort hofft sie
endlich ihren seelenfrieden zu finden
mittlerweile hat auch die wissenschaft
einen sprung nach vorne immer gerade in
amerikas dna analysen zu erklärende
herkunft sehr populär geworden ist
sandra das vergleichen ihres erbgutes
weiter
ich bin auf zwei amerikanische datenbank
registriert habe ich aber nicht groß
sieht raff ak und mit einem facebook
einfach mal googlen mit dna das macht
kann ich hätte und dann ist marco dna
detektivs und dieser sie im ganzen hof
von amerikaner drauf war eigentlich für
die vorfahren suchen oder auch mutter
vater und die brüder und das habe ich
dann auch gestartet dann hat sich über
gmunden und zwar auf dessen professor
verlegen muss ich ganz fest mit der dna
der befassen
zum glück sehr gut deutsch können um ihr
hand dann ziemlich schnell
messenger privater hand geschrieben und
er hat immer wieder anhalten
[Musik]
mit dieser hoffnung im gepäck fliegen
sandra agnoli nach san francisco
[Musik]
sandra und rolli machen sich auf den weg
jenen professor aus orient zu treffen
der rätsel schließlich gelöst hat im
nördlichen kalifornien legt man jedoch
gerne auch mal eine pause ein
er hat sich richtig brief eine gerade
haltung zu heftig
im abgelegenen hotel erinnert sich
sandra noch einmal an die jahrelange not
mit ihrem halbwissen nachdem sie beim
gynäkologen ihrer mutter immer wieder
auf granit gebissen hat beginnt sie mit
hilfe ihres partners selbst zu
recherchieren oder uni studiert und
sehen wir oft die zentralbibliothek
fängt den sieht für siege von denen
bürger zurückweist und annehmen wo mit
medienart fanghand und amerikanische
staatsbürgerschaft geschrieben
ja dann bin ich auf den navajo den und
haben dankbar ich habe kunden bestimmen
deshalb kontaktiert sandra den
potenziellen samenspender der heute als
arzt in san francisco lebt er allerdings
streitet die vaterschaft ab und die
haben einfach nicht glaubt kann es nicht
klappt widerstand so viel das genau zu
studieren wie sie damals dass er heute
trainiert spendet die anderen hatten die
routinierte telefonhörer tanke und dann
hat er wirklich noch optisch für mich
seit ich bin nicht dein vater kann und
dann haben ihn natürlich mega messe
brühl hannover
aber ich kanns gegen geld gehabt will
einfach christi alle andere sache
bastian nicht als normalen dahin geht wo
alles zusammen passt dass das so möglich
und ein hahn ich sehe facebook bietet
tochter vor dem nähen und ich haben dann
ihres bild gefunden war das bild eher
wenig und diagonal die gleichen augen
einfach nur als einfach und ich kann
damit ihre kontakte via facebook
und was ich schreiben kann wirklich der
tochter geschrieben die cdu den dna-test
machen aber sie hatten einfach nicht wer
lebt hier
wer sagt die wahrheit sonders gewissheit
das ist der arzt aus san francisco sein
muss kommt erst ins wanken als gregory
anderson mit ihr kontakt aufnimmt
er hatte sich zu ihrem facebook aufruf
gemeldet und gesagt es gäbe noch viele
recherchemöglichkeiten
[Musik]
und ich will sehen aber ein großer
dna-test machen vor amerika der größte
nicht was in amerika gibt auf einmal
dritter
allein in den usa haben in den letzten
jahren über zehn millionen menschen
solche die in art tests gemacht
da kommen gewaltige datenmengen zusammen
und experten können daraus die
erstaunlichsten informationen
herauslesen
sanders hoffnung wächst wieder
in crescent city im norden punkt von
kalifornien treffen sich die beiden zum
ersten mal persönlich auch der biologe
freut sich wieder mal mit schweizern in
kontakt zu kommen
als junger mann hatte er einige jahre in
zürich gewohnt und studenten leben
genossen heute ist ahnenforschung das
große hobby des wissenschaftlers noch
einmal erklärte sandra was man aus ihrer
dna alles heraus lesen kannst also man
sieht also französisch und deutsch 50
prozent und großbritannien
die meisten leute sehen dazu sagen das
ist gut dass ich habe etwas gutes für
conti franken gekommen und aber es gibt
etwas noch wichtig nein man sieht auch
der ärger tafel das heißt cousine die dr
mit mit mir teilen haben gelernt regel
über sofort klar
besonders vermutete samenspender ist es
nicht ein und aus und das stimmt nicht
mit sounds dr wir müssen das war für
mich eine große enttäuschung
und dann ist mir auf einmal in den sinn
gekommen ich habe noch schnabel die
zettel oder ich gebe ihnen diese namen
durch das haus gefunden das stimmt
einfach nicht
und bei nummer drei habe ich gesagt dass
er euch machen wir morgen weiter hast du
gesagt hat du hast mir den namen gegeben
und mir gesagt du musst strafe also ich
habe weiter gearbeitet dann habe ich
sehr schnell seine eltern gefunden und
seinen vorfahren gefunden und ein lakers
gestorben
inzwischen jahr 2006 sind
und selbst als seine vorfahren gefunden
und einen lebenslauf befunden
aber es stimmt alles stimmt ich gehe es
ihr aber sie schreibe ich gehe jetzt
doch gebe es ihr und bekomme ich etwas
schreibt was er ist das so ist es aber
anhand von foto und dem lebenslauf
wusste ich eigentlich schon dass das
mein vater ist dafür habe das foto
gesehen und die augen und ich habe
gewusst er ist mein vater er ist er ist
es ich bin angekommen
aus diesem lebenslauf konnten wir dann
lesen dass ich noch drei haupttäter habe
von dieser familie das sind aber keine
spender kinder das sind dann richtige
kinder die waren eine richtige familie
während sandra ihre herkunft endlich
einwandfrei klären kann
mit rolli in einem amerikanischen
supermarkt für mich ich denke das passt
dass sie ihre wurzeln ihr verdienst
gregory hat einen stammbaum erstellt von
sandras neuer familie war das nicht eine
riesige enttäuschung nach alldem suchen
dass der vater bereits gestorben ist und
als lauf ich damals den tischen ganz
wirklich ganz lieb sie mir ich bin froh
dass ich ihn endlich endlich gefunden
haben und dass ich mehr ist kann wir
erfahren über mini herkunft so nahe ist
sandra zu ihrem ziel gekommen und hat
zum glück noch halbbrüder die mehr über
den verstorbenen vater wissen die zeigen
allerdings zunächst wenig interesse
daran plötzlich eine halbschwester zu
bekommen
genau genommen ist sandra nach amerika
gereist ohne zu wissen um die brüder
überhaupt bereit sind sie zu treffen
aber dann die überraschung
der jüngste halbbruder ist endlich
einverstanden war mit sie kennenzulernen
kommuniziert und es ist überhaupt nicht
sicher dass mir alles gesehen hat zieht
und mit treffer in letzter minute sagte
stunde fahren dürfen sich
[Musik]
nun geht es erneut quer durch
kalifornien nach greenville 200
kilometer östlich von san francisco um
dance jüngsten sohn zu besuchen
allerdings möchte er unter keinen
umständen eine kamera dabei haben auch
respektiert sander den ausdrücklichen
wunsch aller drei söhne dass weder namen
noch bilder ihres vaters veröffentlicht
werden allein die begegnung mit einer
völlig unbekannten halbschwester wird
aufwühlen genug werden
[Musik]
green wird ein kleines städtchen in der
sierra nevada in diese einsame und wilde
gegenzug sanders vater nach seinem
medizinstudium an verschiedenen orten
als arzt zu praktizieren zuletzt viele
jahre in dieser ehemaligen goldgräber
siedlung inmitten von ureinwohner land
direkt an der berühmten sentry pacific
eisenbahnlinie die bis zur
amerikanischen westküste geht
die heimat ihres vaters und die erste
begegnung mit ihrem halbbruder hat
sandra jetzt ihre wurzeln gefunden ich
einfach ganz natürlichen umgang sie und
sehr offen und sehr viel sehr viel brühe
und einige so lang her sieht mein vater
gestorben ist und sich für ihn schwierig
und weise verarbeitet
ach ja total
[Musik]
sander kommt noch einmal zu ehemaligen
wirkungsstätte ihres vaters zurück das
ist die klinik um im vater geschafft hat
und es hat eine ganze region an schienen
nur zwei ärzte im ganzen tal und
erscheint mit den texaner zum die
friedlich am leben zu halten
irgendwann ist einfach zu wenig und
jetzt sieht man es kaum gelohnt die
klinik überhaupt nur weiterführen
wir sind im halbfinale und dann hat mir
wirklich alles sehr genau erklärt und
sich per zufall auf die kliniken können
ihnen und eine ganze 20 jahre inszeniert
ist
türen gehen auf die brüder wollen auch
einmal in die schweiz kommen eine neue
familienbande entsteht auch wenn der
gemeinsame vater nicht mehr dabei sein
kann
ich bin 40 so intensiv und so sexy und
jetzt bin ich mal am ziel und ich weiß
auch alles über ihn auf alles was man
wissen und einfache von mega mega band
[Musik]
gemacht